buongiorno a tutti oggi proverò a
raccontarmi raccontarvi la mia storia
che poi è la storia anche
dell'associazione di cui faccio parte
che appunto si chiama agenda praiano
questa associazione nel giro di qualche
anno come ho appena sentito sta creando
questo piccolo grande progetto di
ingegneria civica per noi è un grande
esperimento stiamo provando in qualche
modo a trasformare il paese di praiano
in un museo giardino della ceramica a
cielo aperto
[Musica]
faccio un passo indietro e vi racconto
come è nata questa storia tutto ebbe
inizio nel 2013 quando il giornalista
claudio gatti ex corrispondente del sole
24 anni stati uniti aveva deciso che era
il momento per lui di fare qualcosa di
importante in italia nel suo paese lui
quando era giovane si trasferì negli
stati uniti quindi ha vissuto
praticamente tutta la sua gioventù ma
poi anche negli anni successivi negli
stati uniti e ha visto da vicino tua
provare con mano e soprattutto ha
cercato di osservarne le peculiarità di
quel processo di rigenerazione urbana
che è stata a new york new york nei
negli anni 70 80 ancora ricordata come
una città pericolosa una città dove
forse non era il caso vive soprattutto
nel centro città
e invece oggi quello che noi vediamo
come senza al park il polmone verde a
pensare che bene negli anni 70 un luogo
praticamente abbandonato la rinascita di
questo di questa città la nascita di
central park
c'è stata grazie all'impegno dei
cittadini grazie all'impegno dei
comitati delle associazioni che in
collaborazioni con gli imprenditori in
collaborazione con le istituzioni sono
riusciti quindi dal basso anche loro a
realizzare questo grande progetto quindi
claudio gatti ormai prossimo alla
pensione aveva deciso ebbene adesso il
momento che io metta in campo tutte le
mie esperienza vissuta soprattutto come
cittadino negli stati uniti riesca
organizza realizzare qualcosa di
importante per il mio paese che l'italia
claudio gatti è un caro amico di luigi
zingales che forse voi conoscete un
professore di economia della chicago
booth school of economics una persona
che
condotto molti studi sul ruolo del
capitale sociale e l'influenza questi
hanno sulle trasformazioni e sul
l'evoluzione dei sistemi finanziari nei
paesi e bene insieme hanno realizzato
questo modello che oggi definiamo di
empowerment sociale che si chiama agenda
comune e loro all'epoca l'hanno nominato
appunto un progetto per l'italia perché
un progetto per l'italia perché la loro
idea è quella di utilizzare il sistema
di funzionamento delle società di
venture capital per anziché generare
capitale finanziario l'idea era quella
di generare capitale civico quindi ebert
empowerment sociale ovvero fornire con
gli strumenti a tutte quelle
associazioni e quei comitati a quella
parte virtuosa della popolazione seppur
ristretta che vuole cambiare le cose ma
non sa come fare non sa dove partire
quindi analizzato questo modello che
brevemente vi illustro in verità esiste
un comitato di gestione che selezione
progetti un comitato di garanti che
gestisce che controlla che vengano
sviluppati in maniera coerente
poi c'è una piattaforma che ha
l'obiettivo di mettere insieme tutti
questi progetti affinché si crei anche
un circolo virtuoso dove un progetto
generale credibilità e dia fiducia ad
altre persone per poter poi realizzare
altri progetti non fino una banca di
capitale civico perché parla con sistemi
finanziari e trasportando questo modello
nel mondo il capitale civico
l'idea era quella di monitorare tutte le
ore di lavoro che venivano utilizzate
venivano fatte volontariamente dai
cittadini conservarli in questa banca di
capitale civico ma quindi che c'entra
brano traiano con claudio gatti chicago
ebbene claudio decise che il posto
ideale per realizzare e per testare per
la prima volta questo modello sarebbe
stata praiano prenotato un caso perché
lui anni prima aveva acquistato una casa
in questo paese e veniva a passarci le
sue stati e decise che quello forse era
l'ecosistema ideale perché c'è un
benessere diffuso ma al tempo stesso c'è
tutta una serie di problemi la fortuna
di praiano e che si trova nel centro
della costiera amalfitana noi diciamo in
maniera un po campanilistica nel cuore
della costiera amalfitana equidistante
da amalfi ed a positano e questo da un
lato rappresentato per noi una grande
opportunità in termini economici ma allo
stesso tempo un grande rischio perché
abbia visto in poco tempo come
immaginare un paese di duemila abitanti
si vede arrivare 200mila persone che
dormono nel nostro paese e mangiate
effetti possono avere sulla comunità
sulla trasformazione che genera sulla
comunità allora abbiamo pensato bene di
fare un'associazione si chiama in linea
con l'agenda comune si chiama agenda
praiano e cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
prodotto chiesto fiducia alle persone è
stato un processo interessante perché è
una stata una perfetta commistione tra
un processo bottom up topdown bottom up
perché noi l'abbiamo sposato e quindi
senza le forze nostre dei cittadini
presi non sarebbe stato possibile
topdown perché siamo stati in qualche
modo sensibile attenti e anche come dire
genuini nel credere nell'idea di
qualcuno che non era di praiano che non
conosceva benissimo prendo le sue
dinamiche interne quindi questa unione
di forze ha generato questa associazione
ci siamo dati subito una programmazione
a 7 anni 2013 2020 è importante per
iniziare una visione non c'è non solo
fare un qualcosa che tempo nessun
problema per l'anno dopo
ma cercare di immaginare cosa sarebbe
potuta essere praiano in un momento di
trasformazione così forte
tra sette anni tant'è vero che oggi
stiamo iniziando a lavorare sulla
programmazione per il 2027 e soprattutto
c'è stata una prima grande cosa
importante voi lo sapete siamo
conterranei da da queste parti funziona
così sia un progetto si va al comune si
bussa alla porta si chiede un
finanziamento molte volte con la
possibilità di finanziare la porta viene
chiusa il progetto non si fa non abbia
deciso in altro modo una volta raccolti
questi 20 mila euro abbiamo scritto un
progetto abbiamo cercato il bando giusto
e quindi non adattato il progetto un
bando ma abbiamo cercato il bando è
giusto che facesse al nostro caso e
abbiamo presentato donato il progetto al
comune chiedendo loro una semplice
collaborazione cioè essere partner in
questo processo abbia vinto il primo
bando nel 2015 e abbiamo installato le
prime 150 opere d'arte oggi praiano è un
vero e proprio museo giardino a cielo
aperto diciamo in questo modo perché ci
siamo molto ispirati nel concetto del
parc güell di barcellona questa unione
meravigliosa di ceramica arte e natura
chiaramente la ceramica perché come voi
lo sapete la costiera amalfitana
vive anche di questo vi sono molti
artigiani mi sono molte fabbriche quindi
nel modo per valorizzare una parte del
nostro artigianato ma allo stesso tempo
l'arte rappresenta per noi anche una
forma di resistenza perché quando
abbiamo realizzato queste opere d'arte
gli artisti che abbiamo selezionato che
sono stati 8 nel primo caso avevano un
compito preciso realizzare le opere che
parlassero di praiano a praiano infine
turisti cioè praiano ritornava come
primo fruitore di questo processo e
serviva a noi in qualche modo per
cementificare una parte di paese che già
stava scomparendo in queste foto delle
opere e queste queste opere raccontano
una parte il nostro paese che è
veramente sta scomparendo l'ho visto
conoscendo i ragazzi delle scuole alcuni
di loro già non conoscendo delle storie
che mi hanno raccontato i miei nonni
quindi abbassato una generazione per
perdere un capitale immenso che ci
avrebbe in poco tempo fatto dimenticare
che siamo
non è stato per me anche sempre facile e
qui forse c'è stata la mia prima grande
lezione che ho imparato perché noi
abbiamo perso un primo bando nel 2013
o meglio non abbiamo partecipato perché
non eravamo convinti del progetto si sta
facendo avremo voleva dire partecipare a
quel bando europeo perdere già un poco
della diciamo della sostanza del
progetto quindi non l'abbiamo avuto
subito svendere il secondo l'odio verso
nel 2014 era un fondo un por fesr della
regione campania e in quel caso la
nostra parte l'avevamo fatta nel momento
della selezione ci rendemmo conto che il
nostro progetto
neanche è stato preso in considerazione
perché mancava un documento che
probabilmente è sfuggito nella
presentazione
lì c'è c'è piombato il mondo addosso ci
è caduto addosso perché in un attimo
quello che è il nostro fatalismo tipico
del sud quella che è la sfiducia nelle
istituzioni non abbiamo uno dei più alti
tassi di sfiducia nelle istituzioni ce
l'hanno subito riportate verso i paesi
sentiva dire non mi vogliono far fare il
progetto non mi vogliono far cambiare e
così via
non vi nego che io mi ero anche molto
abbattuto perché però il principale
referente sul territorio mentre claudio
gatti rimane o negli stati uniti però
lui mi chiamò e mi disse è stata colpa
nostra è stata colpa nostra perché
avremo devo controllare fino all'ultimo
anche lì dove non era responsabilità
nostra cosa mancava nel proprio
eto'o non ti preoccupare capita un'altra
occasione non succederà lo stesso errore
e così è stato abbiamo vinto questo
bando ovviamente 250 mila euro per la
prima fase che trovando anche altri
sponsor e con la con la collaborazione
del comune abbiamo speso in questo
progetto e 380mila euro
tutto questo perché abbiamo sfruttato un
grande capitale reputazionale delle
figure che erano state coinvolte in
questo progetto ma a me mi ha dato
un'altra grande possibilità ovvero gli
ho potuto comparare il risultato nostro
con quello di altri 20 progetti in
quanto i 20 progetti che sono stati
finanziati in ugual modo della regione
campania e vi riporto due elementi che
per me sono stati significativi
queste opere che voi vedete oltre a
questi sono stati i restauri di
affreschi del 1400 in un commento
noi abbiamo speso el 85 per cento
dell'importo del progetto su beni di
natura duratura c'è la nostra idea era
quella di lasciare un qualcosa di
materiale che potesse essere poi un
degenerare in futuro tutta un'altra
serie di opportunità
oltre al valore sociale che che
conteneva è l'altro elemento molto
importante riguarda la comunicazione noi
siamo riusciti in poco tempo con una
piccola cifra a comunicare il progetto
dappertutto
quando ho detto 85 per cento del dei dei
fondi utilizzati per i beni natura
duratura per farvi un esempio stati i
progetti che hanno speso il 75 per cento
con lo stesso bando quindi stessi
requisiti per realizzare un un semplice
evento per promuovere un territorio che
però ha una durata di un giorno il
giorno dopo se non comunicato bene
finisce quindi io mi sono trovato
catapultato in questo progetto e non
avevo ancora capito la porta del
progetto finché un giorno non ho
ricevuto questa e mail ovvero io ho
fatto una semplice candidatura e mi sono
trovato all'improvviso selezionato tra
oltre 15.000 application alla fondation
summit che si è tenuto a chicago ormai
due anni fa li ero con me c'erano altri
in quattro cinquecento ragazzi a tutto
il mondo e non posso credere
immaginati non può dormire quando lui
conosciuta alle 2 di notte questa email
ero sveglio non ho dormito tutta la
notte
non ci credevo mi sono potuto
confrontare con tutti i ragazzi più
svegli intelligenti con un'esperienza
delle spalle larghe molto più delle mie
a portare un piccolo progetto di un
piccolo paese che per avere un'ambizione
molto grande e noi però in questo
momento non eravamo riusciti a
realizzare quello volevamo cioè
innescare questo questo circolo virtuoso
di altri progetti però grazie a questo a
questa chiamata grazie al fatto che dopo
tutti mi hanno voluto sentire ha dovuto
ascoltare la mia storia è successo un po
con questo processo che ci aspettavamo
però vi raccontano al metodo velocissimo
questo è un museo in questo museo alla
prima sera noi avevamo una cena
funzionava in questo modo si entrava qua
parliamo questo il museo delle scienze
di chicago si entrava si prendeva un
numerino e quel numerino era il tavolo
che ci veniva assegnato come l'ho fatto
io lo ha fatto anche obama l'ha fatto
miscela ha fatto il principe harry che
era tra gli ospiti quindi può
tranquillamente capitare seduto affianco
a obama se fosse successo non avrei
mangiato sarei scomparso completamente
però per fortuna il successo in quel
tavolo
ogni tavolo avevo un moderatore sono
delle tavole rotonde che dovevano farlo
dovevano far sì che ognuno si dove
ognuno si doveva esprimere su come
esprimere su un tema che loro ponevano
al centro del tavolo perché per loro
tutti eravamo importanti però è un'altra
cosa mi ha colpito quella sera o meglio
il giorno dopo io non sapevo che aveva
fianco a fianco a me sapevo che era
qualcuno sicuramente con una storia
interessante però al mio capito il
giorno dopo
noi dato il giusto che lo di attenzione
perché il giorno dopo la stessa persona
che raffia anche a meno di fronte a me
in verità era lo speaker di un panel a
cui ho partecipato allora mi sono
chiesto ma perché io ieri sera quella
persona ce lo affianco a me perché non
l'ho ascoltata in quel modo
ogni semplicemente perché di fronte a
melito un altro peso come oggi sta
succedendo in questa sala
allora mi sono reso conto perché
aspettare che dopo un nome ci sia una
sigla ci sia un nome di una società di
qualcos'altro per aspettare e ascoltare
dar valore a quelle parole la volevo
fare prima mi son perso tante occasioni
quindi io ricordo che in quell'occasione
obama ci disse una voce può cambiare una
stanza allora spero che in questo caso
anche stasera la mia semplice voce
abbiamo potuto lasciarvi qualcosa
spero che a questo punto più voci tutti
insieme possono cambiare un paese o
realizzare qualcosa di importante e vi
lascio con questa foto che mi hanno
fatto in cui appunto credo ancora nel
potere sociale delle persone grasse